the king is said to be
pleased and relieved that his younger
son took the opportunity to come today
for this his mother his father and
mother-in-law's first day stepmother I
should say as more and more Royals start
to arrive now waiting for the prince and
princess of Wales Prince of Wales now
the heir to the throne of course and
were promised all three of the
youngsters will be here as we wait for
them to get out of the car Dominic is
here with me Dominic we've seen lots of
kings and queens and leaders of State
arriving we have we've we've just seen
um this is the close members of the
members of the close royal family have
seen descendants of George VI George V
the Duke and Duchess of Gloucester the
Earl of Snowden we've seen the uh the
Prince Michael of Kent and various other
dukes and Duchess is as you say before
that we've had royalty from around the
world now traditionally royalty from
foreign Royals have not been invited to
British coronations because coronations
are seen as kind of intimate ceremonies
between the Monarch and and its creative
but an exception has been made on this
occasion so a very fine site they were
as well per se proceeding into the Abbey
our late Queen's youngest son uh now the
Duke of Edinburgh of course Edward also
arriving with uh Sophie Wessex and their
two children are seen as the late Queens
favorite member of the not immediate
royal family if you will and taking the
opportunity to just reorganize their
dress ahead of heading into Westminster
Abbey this the coronation Abbey and in
just a few moments time we will see the
king and queen arrive